Dis Einstein, tu veux faire quoi cette nuit ?
La même chose que chaque nuit Fabien,
tenter de conquérir les jeux de hasard.
*Musique sympatique*
Salut, aujourd'hui on va parler des jeux de hasard
des martingales qui sont des systèmes pour essayer de gagner à des jeux de hasard
On va aussi parler des méthodes qui permettent d'essayer de gagner au loto
alors forcément y'aura un petit peu de statistiques et de probabilités !
Mais trois fois rien, c'est juste pour vous illustrer.
Depuis toujours l'homme veut gagner aux jeux d'argent,
mais pas des petites sommes,
des grosses sommes en plus.
Ce qui est drôle d'ailleurs parce que c'est le rêve qui nourris ça, si y'a
pas beaucoup de chances de gagner une très grosse somme
y'aura plus de joueurs que si y'a beaucoup plus de chances de gagner une somme plus raisonnable.
Pour commencer cette vidéo on va parler des martingales,
mais qu'on soit d'accord sur une chose :
en aucun cas je ne vous conseille de jouer de l'argent à des jeux de hasard
Comme dit le proverbe au final c'est toujours le casino qui est gagnant.
Ceci étant dit, voyons ce qu'on appelle la martingale, le système le plus classique pour essayer de tromper le hasard
Le but d'une martingale c'est de s'optimiser sur un jeu à 50/50,
c'est à dire ou un choix à 50% de chance de gagner, face à l'autre choix qui a également 50% de chances de gagner.
En fait c'était très clair dès le départ !
Vous allez retrouver des application de ce système pour la roulette, pour des paris sportifs...
Alors comment ça se passe une martingale :
Imaginons que je veuille gagner un euro dans un système ou si je mise 1, je récupère 1.
Si je mise 2 je récupère 2 etc.
Comme c'est la mode des Hand spinner on va dire qu'on joue à la roulette.
Parce que... parce que ça tourne... T'as compris le... le truc.
A la roulette si je joue une couleur, c'est à dire rouge ou noir et que c'est ma couleur qui sors alors je double ma mise.
ça ressemble à du 50/50, en vrai c'est pas ça,
mais on va pas s'attarder dessus c'est juste pour dire qu'il y a le zéro qui rentre en jeu à la roulette
et le zéro c'est pas une couleur, c'est pas le rouge, c'est pas le noir, c'est autre chose encore.
Ce qui permet déjà un petit peu de biaiser le côté 50/50.
On fonctionne sur deux règles. La première règle c'est que si je gagne, je dois changer de couleur.
Donc j'encaisse mon gain et si je jouais rouge je joue noir.
Et si je perd alors je dois maintenir cette couleur en doublant ma mise.
Par exemple je joue sur noir 1 euro
et c'est rouge qui sort alors du coup je vais jouer 2 euros
et c'est encore rouge qui sort alors je joue 4 euros
mais c'est encore rouge qui sors alors je joue 8 euros
c'est encore rouge qui sors je joue 16 euros
c'est noir qui sors. Alors je récupère ma mise de 16 et je gagne 16 de plus.
Ces 16 de plus ça couvre mes pertes, donc 8 + 4 + 2 + 1, ça fait 15
plus le 1 euro de départ que je cherchais à gagner.
Ouais, j'ai fais tout ça pour un euro du coup.
Et c'est là que ce système est quand même pervers au final parce que déjà il faut avoir beaucoup, beaucoup de fonds avec soi pour gagner peu.
C'est le principe de la martingale. Là on l'a fait en 5 coups mais imaginez qu'en disant noir durant 10 coups se soit rouge et zéro qui sorte comme ça
et que se soit seulement au dixième coup que le noir sorte,
selon la martingale au dixième coup je serais à 512 euros.
Ce qui veut dire que sur les 9 coups d'avant cumulés j'aurais dépensé 511 euros
donc pour gagner 1 euro au dixième coup il fallait que j'ai 1023 euros de liquidité avec moi.
Pour gagner 1 euro.
Donc si tu veux gagner 10 euros, tu vois ce qu'il te reste à faire.
Et pour cette vidéo j'ai pu me faire aider par des gens qui s'y connaissent un petit peu plus que moi en mathématiques
et qui ont vérifié un petit peu les tirages de sortie des casinos en ligne.
Et bien il n'est pas si rare qu'une couleur sorte 10 fois d'affilée,
même 10 fois d'affilée, le zéro et encore 3 fois la même couleur.
La plupart des casinos, eux, maintenant ont des tables limitées,
c'est à dire qu'à un moment donné la martingale ne suffira plus à couvrir les dettes même si vous aviez de l'argent en illimité pour jouer.
Mais est-ce qu'on peut faire une vidéo sur les jeux de hasard sans parler du loto ? Non, évidemment que non !
C'est le jeu de hasard par excellence pour gagner de l'argent.
C'est à dire que même les gens qui ne jouent pas au loto ont parfois la conversation de "qu'est-ce que je ferais si je gagnais au loto".
Encore aujourd'hui pour le loto il y a des personnes qui font un classement pondéré des numéros annoncés
C'est à dire qu'ils font des statistiques numéro par numéro,
ils font des probabilités numéro par numéro
en fonction de tous les tirages du passé.
Ils le font tous seuls, avec leurs petits doigts musclés
Ce qui n'est pas forcément nécessaire parce que j'ai cherché et on retrouve des sites internet
où y'a le classement toutes les semaines, les numéros les plus chauds les numéros les plus froids
Les statistiques ou les probabilités numéro par numéro.
Et donc après il faut choisir son camp. Est-ce qu'on joue vraiment au hasard ?
Est-ce qu'on joue en fonction des statistiques des numéros sortis ?
Est-ce qu'on joue en fonction des probabilités des numéros qui sont sortis ?
Ou est-ce qu'on fait justement un classement pondéré de tout ça ?
On peut également utiliser un système réducteur
qui permet de couvrir un nombre de numéros sur plusieurs grilles.
Parce qu'après j'ai calculé y'a des trucs marrants avec le loto.
Par exemple, il faudrait jouer 20 grilles au loto
pour être sûr et certain que quelque soit le tirage on ait deux numéros justes.
Et là on comprend pourquoi c'est si peu rentable de gagner seulement deux numéros.
Ils se sont dit on va faire les gains en fonction du nombre de chance qu'ils ont de remporter le gain,
c'est logique. Et beh si on le regardait un petit peu ce nombre de chances.
C'est un calcul factoriel, ce qui est cool c'est que je ne vais même pas vous demander de le comprendre.
Si je prend l'exemple de l'euromillion le calcul s'écrirait comme ça :
Parce qu'il y a 5 tirages parmis 50 numéros,
puis 2 tirages parmi douze numéros.
Donc on va faire (50*49*48*47*46)*(5*4*3*2*1)
C'est pô fini !
Multiplié encore par (12*11)*(2*1)
Ce qui nous donne une chance sur 139 838 160 de gagner à l'euromillion.
Et là y'a des malins qui se disent "bah pourquoi on se mettrait pas en regroupement pour jouer toutes les grilles d'un coup
et comme ça après on partage... pas bête du tout !
Mais complètement interdit, déjà c'est illégal de se regrouper comme ça à autant pour jouer au loto
Individuellement on n'a pas le droit de jouer toutes les grilles possibles
et à 2 euros 50 la grille ça nous ferait plus de 350 millions d'euros !
Et même les super cagnottes elles ne dépassent pas les 350 millions d'euros.
Parce que je vous l'ai dit, les mecs y bossent quand même y réfléchissent
Ce qui n'empêche qu'il est très intéressant de noter les tirages et d'essayer de faire un classement pondéré
ou d'essayer de faire des systèmes réducteurs.
C'est à la fois ludique et stimulant de toute manière, ça devient un challenge
Et on se dit qu'on pourrait le faire sur des jeux un peu plus simples ou y'a 1 chance sur 500 000 de gagner.
C'est le cas du rapido par exemple
Mais le problème c'est qu'à chaque fois on tombe contre mon conseil qui est ne jouez pas d'argent sur des jeux de hasard.
Mais bon, ça reviendrait à dire qu'il faudrait un loto gratuit, en fait. *ricanement*
Ben ça existe.
Et ça s'appelle bravoloto, quand j'ai découvert l'application j'ai discuté avec eux pour réfléchir à un partenariat pour sortir cette vidéo là.
Y'a 48 numéros il faut en choisir 5, y'a les 12 signes astrologiques il faut en choisir 2.
Ce qui nous donne déjà, et j'ai fait le calcul, 20 millions de chances en plus de gagner par rapport à l'euromillion.
20 millions de chances en plus ! Une paille.
Je trouve vraiment l'appli cool parce qu'il y a rien à payer, rien du tout.
C'est financé par les publicité
Y'a 1 tirage tous les jours à 20h45, le tirage il est fait en France par un huissier français, c'est bien.
Et également une dizaine de méga-jackpot en plus toute l'année à 1 million d'euros.
Le méga-jackpot, on se met bien avec 1 million d'euros !
Au final ça vous permet de tester des statistiques, des proba, des martingales, les calculs que vous voulez
vous pouvez noter tous les jours les tirages pour essayer d'affiner le votre.
Vous pouvez le faire avec un pendule si ça vous amuse
Vous pouvez essayer d'autres systèmes du martingale spécialement pour le loto,
peu importe puisque c'est gratuit de le faire.
Je vous met un lien pour télécharger bravoloto dans la description.
C'est pas tous les jours que je fais une vidéo en partenariat donc vous pouvez vous dire que c'est cool et que c'est clean.
Merci et bravo bravoloto. ça fait deux bravos.
Comme d'habitude je vous donne la date et l'heure de la prochaine vidéo, ce sera samedi prochain à 11 heures.
On le note, on s'organise pour être là.
Mais j'ai le don d'ubiquité puisque je serais à un autre endroit en même temps,
je serais à La Rochelle, ce samedi 24 à 10h45 à la librairie Calligrammes
pour vous dédicacer le livre.
Et le 28 juin je serais à côté de Caen à Mondeville, se sera au Cultura, j'ai plus l'horaire en tête allez voir sur le site de Cultura ça doit être noté.
Et puis si vous vous posez une question sur le livre y'a le lien dans la description.
Merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo, j'espère vraiment qu'elle vous aura plu,
n'hésitez pas à me le faire savoir avec le hum hum... je ne le prononcerais même pas !
N'hésitez pas à bous abonner si ce n'est pas déjà fait,
et donc, rendez-vous samedi à 11h. Ciao !
Sub by Mat Spirit <3
*La musique est cool quand même !*